i learned that i didn't have to be a
hundred percent better than everybody
else
i didn't even have to be ten percent
better than everybody else
i only had to be one percent better than
everybody else
at everything there's no such thing as
accidental achievements
[Music]
it's the bridge self-discipline is the
bridge between
good intentions and good actions be
present to the season you're currently
in
and prepare to soar to fly in your next
season
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
habits you should make daily for the
next 30 days
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one out work
everybody with busy timberquay if you
follow
any pursuit or endeavor any form of
conquest
sports business arts culture anything
where human beings endeavor to perform
better than other human beings
there's something called the law of
averages which is that there are people
who are below the average
but the average person fits into this
big bowl in the middle
called average then you get this tiny
little
group of people at the top my
fascination has always been
with the people at the top think about
um the world's fastest man of all time
usain bolt
so is usain bolt the world's fastest man
because he's more talented than anybody
else
or is he the world's fastest man because
he has a genetic advantage
or is he the world's fastest man because
he has the best training
is he the world's fastest man because he
has access to the most advanced science
or is he the world's fastest man because
of all of those
and he's only one percent better than
everybody else
i learned that i didn't have to be a
hundred percent better than everybody
else
i didn't even have to be ten percent
better than everybody else
i only had to be one percent better than
everybody else at everything
go watch sean rhoden when he won mr
olympia i'll never forget there's that
shot of sean rodin coming out
and there's the light from the back and
you see sean rhoden's waist this big
and his shoulders that big and that
beautiful arch up
right now you're probably watching this
going why the hell is was it talking
about bodybuilding
let me tell you why i love things like
bodybuilders and athletes
it's because they have to train tens of
thousands of hours to make that one
percent improvement
that additional one percent is tens of
thousands of hours more than the 99
of the people beneath you so if you're
busy studying for an exam
if you want to be right at the top of
your pile you got to make sure that you
put in more hours
if you're training you've got to do that
too you're running a business
you're going to be up earlier sleep
later work harder when you're in it
so the top one percent when they get
there they make it look effortless
which is the last thing i want to share
with you the curse of genius is it makes
its gift look effortless and so when you
get to the top and you are that top one
percent one of the things you'll realize
is people either won't recognize it
won't reward it
or won't give you your dues why
because you make it look easy if you're
watching usain bolt around 100 meters
he makes it look easy so you want to do
it
so your task look at the things you do
look at where you want to improve and
just ask yourself
how much time are you putting in habit
number two make a perspective shift with
dean graziosi
when i make decisions from a fearful
mindset
i never make a good one i've played too
small
i've missed opportunities i let the
wrong
voices stick in my soul and let the
right ones slip by
when i'm in a fear-based place i don't
listen to personal growth
i don't want to listen to church or a
service on a sunday
i'll go to the news i'll go to my
negative friends it's this weird thing
when you're in a fearful place it's
almost like your subconscious wants it
to be fed
and if you're in that space in that
state of mind
it's almost impossible to design your
bigger future
it's almost impossible to see where
things could go
so what i want to encourage you today if
you're listening or watching
is what lens are you looking through i
have a pair of glasses on right now as
i'm recording this
and you could be looking through two
different lenses or taking two different
paths
one lens is things aren't going to get
better what am i going to do
i don't know how to take care of my
future what if my income goes away
what if this stays for 60 days all those
things could happen
but when you go down that road you can't
make
powerful decisions to change your life
or you can look through the lens
is this is out of my control i didn't
make this happen
i can't fix it i can't make it go any
faster
so i want to look through the lens of
how do i become a better version of me
how do i shut off the lens of fear how
do i shut off
those thoughts going inside of my head
that this won't work out and how do i
shift them
into thoughts that could take me to
where it is that i really want to go
you see i've said this last week if you
listen to my podcast this
the next 90 120 days this is gonna end
could take three months six months
the economy could take three years who
knows
but it's gonna end and who are you to be
at the end of this
are you going to be the person that was
fearful through the entire thing
and you missed the window of opportunity
that the world
opened for you while you were going
through this i've also said this a lot
but i want you to think about this right
now when one door closes another one
opens
duh like dean okay you want me to come
to your podcast to learn something i've
heard for a million years
now i want you to think about this how
many times when one door closes
does someone just stand there and keep
rattling the doorknob like jiggle jiggle
jiggle come on open back up
i want that the job i want the thing
back so many of you
and so many people i've talked to so
many of us you're
fearful about the thing you're losing
but the thing you're losing or afraid
might go away is actually the thing
you've hated or despised for
years what if it's god right now listen
whatever you believe in but
what if you believe god just slam the
door on so many of us
said enough is enough you've been
hesitating too long to read the book do
the course
start your own business let not live in
your fear live in your true purpose i
designed you for more
it's time to get more i know you feel
scared i know you have scarcity
i know you feel uncertainty but what if
this was the time to actually feel
certainty within yourself we can't
control the outside world but we surely
can control what we digest
we surely can control our emotions we
surely can
control what we do with this time that
we have that we're quarantined or need
to stay
home remember back to that door that
closed do you want to be the person that
just sits there and rattles the doorknob
and hoping your old life opens back up
or do you want to turn and say
crap it's time to find a new door and
you might open a few doors that have
nothing behind
them but if we search if we get out of a
fear
mindset and we get into a place of
certainty in our soul that we've been
here
we've been through tough times we've
solved problems listen
if you look at it globally we've been
through horrific times and we solved it
if you look at it nationally your
country has been through
hard times and solved it if you look at
your state your city
your town your home your family
you if you keep narrowing it down you
realize that we've been through
horrible circumstances in our lives and
you're here
you're listening you're watching you're
here to fight another day
all i know in my life i've never made a
great decision when i was scared
i never made a great decision when i was
fearful i've done them in recent time
and they've never worked out
but when i stop and i look at what fear
has cost me
when i look at what being scared to face
this to face the opponent which right
now
is is like a a an invisible war that's
going on
this disease and this virus in the
economy it may be invisible but it's in
front of you
you can either look away and binge on
netflix and listen to the news and get
more scared
and text the friends that'll fuel your
fear or you can say no
i'm going to awaken right now i'm going
to wake up on a whole nother level i'm
going to be energized i'm going to
utilize
every moment of this time and i'm going
to
fill my brain i'm going to fuel my soul
to not have a fear-based mindset but an
empowered energized mindset i'm going to
digest the book
finish the course start the company get
into self-education
whatever it takes listen this is just a
marching call i'm not
pushing you to something this very
moment and telling you must do this
i'm telling you to do something because
being afraid
will keep you playing small so what's up
man it's good to see you i i see you all
over the place i see you hustling
i see your impact in lives doing amazing
stuff on youtube
i want to share whatever works for you
know you're following my following today
but i want to share dude your book built
to serve
you are built to serve there's a
difference when
you know this is i've been an
entrepreneur for an entrepreneur for
over 30 years i've been in the
self-education industry for 24.
can't even seem it doesn't even seem
possible but there's a lot of people
that
when you kind of meet your heroes or you
meet the people behind the book
a habits book a built to serve book a
time management it's like you beat you
meet the guy with the time management
book and he's late getting on stage and
stressed out of his mind in the green
room
like there's no congruency is what i
wanted to say and before we chat today i
just want to honor you and give you
congruency this
what you wrote in this book is really
who you are man you are
built to serve you reach out to my team
all the time and
want to help with youtube and tell us
what we're doing wrong and it's not
you're
not doing it because of finances you're
not doing it because you're trying to
get an edge you're doing it just because
this is who you are man so i love seeing
you out there i love seeing you grow i
love seeing the impact you're making
cool man appreciate it i'm still working
on accepting compliments so
um i'll just say thank you then i'm
gonna keep doing it through this entire
thing to make you feel uncomfortable oh
great
classic dean all right cool well you
know also in that story um
you know you've been really helpful in
getting that book out i remember when i
came to puerto rico
and uh was trying to get feedback on
pre-launch
you and brendan brachard took time
backstage
while you're doing your big event people
paid all this money to come there and
you took time
over lunch for 40 minutes to do a deep
dive
on my strategy um and just super
grateful that you guys did that and
you hooked me up with your warehouse and
you know a whole bunch of things that
dean's a big reason why the book is has
uh uh
just a little piece man just what's up
everybody i see the highs so listen
um appreciate everybody i see all the
cool comments coming in so how can we
deliver some value today how do we help
out besides
um i do got to plug this like if you
didn't check out
uh evans built to serve you should check
it out um the truth is
i'm not all the way done i freaking love
it my biggest problem is every book i
read evan i listen
i i have such a hard time reading i
still have dyslexia
it still doesn't stick so it's taking me
longer but when i actually read a book
it sticks so i highly recommend it and
uh
it's just you it's like it's it's having
a 200 page conversation with you which
is
which is always cool cool man appreciate
it well we also i also have an audiobook
version i read it myself
so there's always oh dude please send
that to me
habit number three work on your
self-discipline john maxwell
self-discipline
the first thing it does it enables you
to go uphill
you can't go uphill without
self-discipline nobody will carry you
uphill
nobody can coach you uphill nobody can
push you uphill
if you go uphill you got to do it
yourself
there are no free rides up here there's
no such thing as
accidental achievements
it's the bridge self-discipline
is the bridge between good intentions
and good actions good intentions is on
one side of the water
and good actions is on the other side
and the bridge
is self-discipline that takes our good
intentions and turns them into
good actions and the question is
is my attitude about self-discipline
is it a tunnel or is it a bridge
if it's a tunnel then
self-discipline is heavy
because it's always about what i'm going
through well i'm going through this well
i'm going through this i'm going to
there's a difference between going
through
something and going to something
when you're going to something you're on
the bridge when you're going through
something you're on the end of the town
at in the tunnel hoping there's some
light at the end of the tunnel
so if self-discipline is a heavy thing
for you
it's a hard thing for you but if
self-discipline
is a journey for you it's easier for you
is it a bridge or is it a tunnel am i
going through it
oh hope i get there or am i going to it
secondly self-discipline is the
difference between temporary
success and sustained success
because the uphill journey is all the
way
you don't get flat land and you don't
get down
land you it's just all up land
and so the core of all success the core
of all success principles
is the core of it is self-discipline
most people want what i call a quick fix
okay john okay okay talk to me talk to
me
help me out here what what's the
quickest way for me
to be very wealthy highly influential
and very successful in life just you
know it's just cut
out the just give me the just
straight quick fast
easy way there's no such thing
it's uphill all the way
and self-discipline is the vehicle that
gets you there
how about number four be present with
lisa nichols
so today's conversation is really
moving from the you that you are to the
you that you're becoming or as i like to
call it
giving yourself your butterfly wings
you know recently i purchased a
caterpillar
and this caterpillar was moving all
around the cup
and the gentleman who i purchased it
from said it's going to turn into a
chrysalis
it's gonna go into a chrysalis and then
it's gonna be wrapped into a cocoon
and it'll take a few days for it to come
out of that cocoon it's gonna move
around as if it were struggling
whatever you do don't disturb the cocoon
and i love that because the mere concept
of a caterpillar
becoming a butterfly
is that it's going to go through all
types of changes
all types of experiences it's going to
look different it's going to feel
different
it's going to feel expanded at while
there were times as a caterpillar it was
double this size
it came all the way down to here as a
caterpillar
then it went into a chrysalis and it was
all white
and now it's gotten all dark
and i'm not sure how many days it will
be maybe four
maybe five even ten even in some cases
14
days before the butterfly emerges
and at that time i'll just cut the
rubber band
without touching the butterfly take the
top off
and the butterfly will fly away and
begin
an entirely new journey but for now
the butterfly is not yet a butterfly
i love what my brother from another
mother sean smith said
when the caterpillar's a caterpillar is
not thinking about being a butterfly
and when the butterflies a butterfly is
not thinking about being a caterpillar
it's focused on exactly where it is so
where in your life
can you be exactly where you are be
present to it
appreciate your past but don't live in
your past don't
wish things were the way they were in
your past in this crazy time
i wish things were the way they were no
allow them to be exactly as they are
be in your present tense i can only
assume that
this caterpillar becoming a butterfly
and this cocoon
is being present to exactly where it is
this other thing that i realize is that
if i were to cut this cocoon
thinking i were helping the butterfly
you know at times how we want to
remove the struggle from our children or
remove the struggle from our spouse
or our partner or remove the struggle
from our family members we want to
we want to rescue them
if i were to rescue this butterfly
even if the wings are already formed if
i were to cut this cocoon
this butterfly would live and die
without ever flying because it's in the
struggle to actually get out of the
cocoon
that the butterfly creates the muscles
and its wings and so i believe
that you are preparing to soar
in this next season be present to the
season you're currently in
and prepare to soar to fly in your next
season
that if it feels as if something in this
season is a struggle
or this something in this season is a
bit contrite if something in this season
is tight
if something in this season is requiring
you to push
and push and push and push it could be
because
you're developing your butterfly wings
it could be
because you're developing the muscles
that are going to help you soar
and without what we call a struggle
which could just be an exercise an
exercise of your patients
an exercise of how fluid and flexible
you can be
an exercise of how you can pivot and
give yourself permission to change
in the midst of what was a flow maybe
this is the time where
you need to be creative on how you
generate revenue
creative on how you get the job done all
the things
that require your muscles to be
developed
at such a time as this
maybe that's your cocoon habit number
five
wear confidence well with priyanka
chopra what changed
with me when i when when i became miss
world
which happened in london actually it
gave me a sense of self
i when i was a teenager i had a lot of
self-esteem issues like most teenagers
do you know
you don't know what's happening with you
you don't know what your body is going
through you don't know
i was gawky my hair was all funny and
frizzy and i didn't know what to do with
it i had so much of it
i yeah and like i hated braids and my
mom would make them
and you know so i had all of those
issues even when i was in america i went
to high school in america and um
i was very confused with who i was and
what i was supposed to be
um i was bullied in school a little bit
not by everyone but
i had a bully and she just made my life
miserable and used to
you know hate on me basis where i came
from i think that's probably all she
knew
to hurt me to call me curry she used to
call me brownie she said go back to your
country on the elephant you came on
and it got really at 15 it got really
hard for me so i decided
you know i want to go back to india and
i went back home and i feel like that's
when destiny played its game
my mum randomly sent photos without
telling me to miss india
i didn't know i just thought that they
called me because i was discovered
yeah teenage egos
but and then um it gave me a sense of
confidence that i could walk onto the
stage
speak the way i speak and i've been
raised to be an opinionated girl my
parents always told me if you have an
opinion don't be afraid to share it
and that's all i did i didn't know how
to walk on heels i tripped on my sari
backstage five times
and then i was in like these velvet
pants with boots on and then i tripped
on it again
i knew it would happen to me on stage i
still have ptsd about it
but but i'm just saying like it it gave
me a sense of
the fact that my personality and the way
i speak and my confidence is what won me
that crown
made me feel like confidence is your
best accessory there is nothing else you
need if you
the only thing you need to wear well is
your confidence and habit number six the
last one before a very special bonus
clip
is love yourself with naveen jane if you
are unhappy with yourself if you
don't love yourself and you are unhappy
with yourself
it doesn't matter you could be in
paradise and you bring that unhappiness
with you
and if you are in love with yourself and
when i say love with yourself i just
want to make sure
i'm not talking about being
self-conceited what i mean
you're not looking for approval from
someone else because
you're comfortable who you are you're
not looking for someone to approve of
who you are
and then if you are happy inside you
could be sitting in a dark corner
and you are happy because you don't need
someone to make you happy
happiness is a choice and people can
make that choice
every single day even if you are very
very rich
you can find a reason to be unhappy i'm
only flying in a gulf stream
five my life sucks look at larry page
he's got 747
converted look at bill gates and he's
flying in this big plane
my life just sucks or you can say oh my
god i
woke up from the bed and my joints don't
eat
how lucky i am i turn around and say wow
look at the women next to me i am just
so
lucky right you can every day you can
find reasons for you to be happy
the happiness is when you are
comfortable with who you are
and the minute you start to prove to
someone else
then you are never successful and never
happy
and that's the reason why i believe the
only way to measure you're successful or
not
the day you become humble is the day you
become successful
if you still have iota of arrogance left
in you then you're still trying to prove
something to yourself
or someone else and the day you let go
of that you're successful
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following will jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps in 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to celebrate alongside with
you
at the beginning you've got more time
than you've got money
and so instead of being upset about that
instead of being upset that
you don't have an inheritance or a rich
aunt or somebody's going to invest in
you
instead of getting upset about that go
do something go
go build your company with your hands
all of your heroes the people that you
look up to that you love that you
respect
they started their companies on their
own
with less than what you have right now
the difference is they didn't accept
the excuse of i need help
i need somebody to come in and save me i
need somebody to come and invest with me
most companies were not started with
giant venture capital funds
right some can but most don't
the companies that your heroes started
they didn't start with it
most likely and so you've got more time
than money use your time wisely even if
you've got
two hours a day great invest those two
hours where are you spending your time
you got
we all have 24 hours right you're
spending eight hours sleeping you're
spending eight hours working you've got
a job
where are those other eight hours going
and how effective are you being
and are you consistently showing up for
your dreams
are you consistently showing up and
putting in the work because doing a
one-off
watching this video and then working
hard today that doesn't count you have
to
work every single day i'm just putting
in an hour a day on your dream
if that's every single day things will
start to happen
the biggest thing you're missing is just
momentum to go
after you achieve some success you'll
end up having more time than money
that's where you can invest in things to
free up your time you invest in
team to free up your time you invest in
advertising and marketing to free up
your time right you can spend money on
things
to get you results
and free up your time because your time
becomes the most important thing
but at the beginning time is what you
got to put in
and it's yes that combination of working
smart and hard but making sure that you
are showing up for your dreams doing
something
every single day
[Music]
if you want to know the seven habits
that will make you one percent better
every day
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i want you to be
the observer thank you
i want to be you to be the observer of
your thinking loop
and how that's spinning out your focus
and then you can shift it
start thinking you know the world has
shifted